Tucker Carlson was fired from Fox two
weeks ago now and there's been a lot of
speculation about what Tucker will do
now that he's been fired where will he
go will he go to some other conservative
Outlets uh will he go out on his own
will he go to the Daily wire you know
Zappa will he come and be a sidekick on
the Matt Walsh show there was a there's
a ton of speculation about that I think
that was really the prevailing theory is
what everybody thought would happen and
um and but it's not apparently we now
have an answer and it's it's a I think
it's a it's a better answer than anyone
had guessed let's uh listen this talk
across is what he posted Twitter
yesterday let's listen
you can't have a free Society if people
aren't allowed to say what they think is
true speech is the fundamental
prerequisite for democracy that's why
it's enshrined in the first of our
constitutional amendments amazingly as
of tonight there aren't many platforms
left that allow Free Speech the last big
one remaining in the world the only one
is Twitter where we are now
Twitter has long served as the place
where our national conversation
incubates and develops Twitter is not a
partisan site everybody's allowed here
and we think that's a good thing
and yet for the most part the news that
you see analyzed on Twitter comes from
media organizations that are themselves
thinly disguised propaganda Outlets you
see it on cable news you talk about it
on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works and we're sick of
it
starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon
that's that is uh that's huge and I have
to say I'm feeling pretty good about our
decision to bring our show to Twitter a
couple weeks ago because
um what you just heard from Tucker is
the exact conversation that I had with
with my team a few weeks ago after we
got demonetized from YouTube
that and it occurred to us that Twitter
is the most powerful Free Speech
platform it's the only really it's it
when it comes to social media
it's not only the most powerful Free
Speech platform but it's in many ways
the only one and um it's also a platform
with hundreds of millions of active
users so I shouldn't say it's the only
free speech platform there are there are
other platforms that allow free speech
um but they're
you know they're uh with all due respect
to the people that run those platforms
they're they're basically internet
ghettos uh and they're places where
conservatives will will banish
themselves and congregate for their own
Echo chamber but they have no cultural
relevance nobody cares nobody's paying
attention to them to these other
platforms
um that have been have been created you
know oftentimes by conservatives in
response to the uh the censorship code
that goes on on the big Tech platforms
um
but Twitter is not that Twitter has
hundreds of millions of active users it
it drives the conversation
um it does that in a way that even
YouTube doesn't
now there's no question that right now
YouTube is a certainly from a technical
perspective it's a better video platform
than Twitter is I don't think anybody
would deny that because YouTube's been
doing this since whatever 2007 I think
uh when it first came into existence
so technically speaking it's a better
video platform right now Twitter has a
lot of Kinks to work out uh the previous
owners of Twitter didn't see its
potential in this Arena and they didn't
try to develop it so there's uh there's
a lot of work to do but Elon and his
team are working on it on it now
um
but
even though YouTube has that going for
it now when it comes to just posting
video it's it's an easier place to do it
and technically they've got a leg up
you know living a healthy yet lifestyle
isn't always easy especially when you're
always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure that
you're getting the proper nutrition
every day which is why I'm a huge fan of
balance of nature balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
make sure that you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
the capsules are packed with 100 whole
food that you can take at any time
balance of nature uses a cold vacuum
process that preserves the natural
phytonutrients and whole fruits and
vegetables encapsulates them for easy
consumption bounce of nature sent a
whole bunch of products down to the
studio for my office to try we love them
all you can make fruits and vegetables a
part of your daily diet your body will
thank you right now balance of nature is
offering 35 off with your first order as
a preferred customer go to
bounceofnature.com use promo code Walsh
for 35 off on your first preferred order
that's bows of nature.com promo code
Walsh
if you've been paying attention to
current events at all these past few
years you know that you need to be
prepared for anything there is no better
place to start than by having a supply
of emergency food on hand right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
go to prepare with walsh.com and grab
this special price before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations enjoy a wide variety of
breakfast lunch dinner drinks and snacks
best of all it's uh delicious don't put
off your emergency preparation any
longer tomorrow maybe too late so go to
prepare with walsh.com and save 200 on
each kit your family needs go to prepare
with walsh.com right now let's prepare
with walsh.com
Twitter I think
if you want to again drive the
conversation
um and the News cycle Twitter does that
a lot more than YouTube does
which is why on YouTube you know you can
have
YouTube stars who have tens of millions
of subscribers and are making millions
of dollars and are extremely successful
but outside of YouTube no one's even
heard of them
okay they can be massive YouTube
celebrities that unless you're in that
audience you've never even heard their
names before
um
and it's uh and that exists of course on
every social media platform exists on
Twitter too there are people who are
kind of famous on Twitter but not
anywhere else but it's there's less of
that if you become prominent on Twitter
then you're going to be in the kind of
national conversation so it makes sense
strategically and now that it's that
that Twitter is run by uh the richest
guy in the world who also happens to be
an advocate of free speech it makes
sense to uh to make this move and I
think that
now with with Tucker coming over is this
was our hope that okay we'll go over to
Twitter and uh it will kind of get out
in front of a of a wave
um and uh with with Tucker coming I'm
saying that I I think that wave that
wave is officially here
and what it also does is it it cuts
cable news out of the equation
completely
now we've known for a long time that
cable news is Antiquated uh the average
cable news viewer I mean the people who
actually sit down
on their couch and turn cable news on
their TV I can't remember the last time
I did that
it's been a long time the people that do
that regularly are all you know average
age of of 97 or something like that
so the audience is like literally dying
um
and all it takes I think to send it over
the The Edge so someone just kind of
like push it over the it's this dying
decrepit thing someone needs to come
along and just kind of nudge it push it
over
and uh I think that's uh that's what
what Tucker is doing here
by going right to Twitter
again a massive platform cutting cable
news out completely
um I think that this is uh I mean
when it comes to to a shake-up in media
we haven't seen anything like this maybe
maybe ever
and it also again vindicates what many
of us saw from the beginning that Elon
Musk buying Twitter is one of the most
significant
um
you know events defending Free Speech
one of the one of the most significant
things for free speech
in modern American history
um but the left is very upset of course
and the news media is extremely upset
for reasons that are in some ways
understandable
um and they're upset that they won't be
able to police what Tucker says that's
really what they're sad about I know
that because that's exactly what they're
saying in fact that's an exact direct
quote from uh from NBC listen
okay well listen Twitter was already
Under Fire from misinformation
disinformation all out lies
anti-Semitism racism before Elon Musk
took over and now it's gotten kind of
crazy right seemingly unmoored uh if you
will will anybody be able to police what
Carlson says or is this the point it's
just a free-for-all I think this is the
point it is a free fall that's what Elon
Musk wants to provide this move by
Tucker May cement the idea of Twitter as
a right-wing website
oh my gosh will anyone be able to police
what he is is he going to be able to
just say things well we can't allow that
who's gonna police him
his kids could be out there saying his
opinions about things we can't allow
that
they're they're really
they are not trying to hide it
just like with their with their child
sexualization agenda they are not trying
to hide it anymore those days are long
gone the days of hiding it are
pretending you know doing of of
doing it but then claiming that they're
not you know trying to enact the agenda
but then say Oh what do you talk about
we're not doing that that's over
it's over when it comes to child
grooming they're doing it out in the
open
and uh when it comes to their war on
Free Speech it's the same deal
they're openly fretting about the fact
that they won't be able to police what
Tucker Carlson says
and we've heard a lot of this from the
left or the last well not just over the
last couple days but especially since
Tucker made his announcement yesterday
that well this this cements it Twitter's
a right-wing website that's all it is
but the great thing is that none of them
will leave you know AOC was whining
about that yesterday
Brian stelter they're they're not going
to leave they're going to stay on
Twitter
because they if that's all it is I mean
you're free to leave
go go to your own then out the tables
have turned here you can go to your own
internet ghetto if you want
but they can't that's what that's one of
the things that makes this so great that
is that all of these uh leftist media
people are addicted to Twitter they
can't put it down they cannot leave it
um
it's uh it's fantastic fantastic news
all right that's gonna do it for us uh
today and in fact for the rest of the
week we'll be off for a few days we'll
be back on Monday talk to you then have
a great week